اسرائيل في صدمه ثلاثيه حجم الخسائر صدمه
واسلوب العمليه صدمه ومصدرها صدمه فقط
لاها ثلاثه جنود وجريحان احدهما ضابط
والموقع عند الحدود مع مصر والمنفذ مصري
برصاص مصريه حقائق كانت كفيله بتحويل
الامر في اسرائيل الى عاصفه من الاسئله
والغضب لم تبددها روايات تضاربت بين جيشها
الذي نشر صور قتلاه على يد من وصفه بمخرب
مصري وهي مفرده تلازم في العاده حديثه عن
الفدائيين والمقاومين وبين روايه الجيش
المصري التي تحدثت عن مطارده فرد امن
لمهرب مخدرات عند الحدود دون اتضاح مصير
المهربين وما الذي اوقع الجنود
الاسرائيليين في الوسط ليقتلوا على
مرحلتين ظل خلالها العسكري المصري مترصدا
لساعات قبل اي يقتل لا صوره الان ولا اسما
للمنفذ الذي تحول الى ايقونه شعبيه مجهوله
لا معلومات قاطعه غير توافق على تحقيقات
ثنائيه بدات فيها اسرائيل واضبه وللغضب
تفسيره لقد ضربت اسرائيل من حيث لم تحتسب
وما جرى حادثا كان او هجوما انما يكشف لما
يراقب عن خيبه مقيمه فان كان وراءه سبب
فكري حركه عداء راسخ لاسرائيل التي خاضت
معها مصر حروبا سالت فيها دماء فانه خوف
لا حل له وان كان ملاحقه في واجب امني
فنتيجته واحده وهي ان رجلا مسلحا ببندقيه
قديمه تفوق على مجموعه مما يوصف بالجيش
الذي لا يقهر وفي ذلك ما فيه من هشاشه
الاداء العسك ري لجنود الاحتلال حين
يتجردون من طائراتهم ودباباتهم
الله يا عبد الودود يا رعب على الحدود على
ان اهم ما ترقبه اسرائيل بعين السياسه هو
الاحتفاء الشعبي الجارف بما صار يوصف
عربيا بالبطل الشهيد بما يكسر رهانها على
تبدل المزاج الشعبي العربي تجاهها رغم
قاطره التطبيع الرسمي التي تصطدم عند اول
منعطف بوجدان جمعي رافض كثير من التفاصيل
لم تكشف بعد ولا يعرف اين ستصل التحقيقات
والمتابعات لكن ما يبدو يقينا انه بالرغم
من السنوات والاتفاقات تكتشف اسرائيل
وغيرها انما في القلب في القلب